Kevin Kevin no we drew up i've looked an
eagle to california you go with okay and
hawing even out on the street yeah I've
been out a year but I violated so right
now I've been out eight years cuz I went
back to jail with you but since your
last prison term you know just a few
months right yeah eight point eight
months eight months yes what were you in
prison for torture aggravated mayhem
torture aggravated mayhem man yeah it's
a car egg torture aggravated mayhem Wow
yes how many years did you hear that I
did 22 years I got a life sentence when
I was 15 years old for that crime a life
size of my 15 he charged measuring the
dough
bout me over to adult court and I lost
my trial was found guilty for my charges
and sentenced to uh what they call an
indeterminate life sentence which was
seven years to life but I did 22 years
on my life sentence what were the
circumstances that guy who was the
ACLU's II offense it wasn't murder no I
wasn't in jail for murder I went to jail
for torture aggravated mayhem
in 1996 I was convicted for burning
someone for a in person gang you know
personal things that I you know I needed
to do I don't want to get into detail
about that but I got convicted for
torturing someone for burning them with
hot spoon was over his body
and I did 22 years for lady reggae yes
sir we can't worry I was part of the
neighborhood power wolves and equal with
California which is perfect Bloods yes
and so that means you go to high school
uh dad I go to high school I dropped out
of school after elementary oh you did
yes
so does even before you went to prison
before multiple years before I went to
prison I was I stopped going to school
I lost all respect for authority I would
decide I became the driven out the link
I was very back here
I grew up I grew up in a single-parent
home my dad was a truck driver my dad
was married so uh you know he stayed in
his marriage
and my mom you know raised three three
boys you know by herself you know she
worked for the post office made good
money kept a roof over our heads clothes
on our back and food in our stomach she
did that's what my mom did that's one
thing you got to say that I think my mom
never you know had us without we had
everything birthdays Christmas instincts
gives me I had a very good life but
growing up in an environment of gang
invested in gang infested environment
such as you know where I look back you
know we got those negative influences in
the streets and you know I became
influenced you know was a you know I was
a I was a little small kid that was very
talented you know I'm saying I know how
to play basketball I was funny I know
how to dance so I had a lot of friends
and I and and and I influenced them you
know I'm saying it through that talent
in a gift but you know when my behavior
changed you know when I started getting
high when I stopped going to school and
I stopped listening to my mom you know I
started adopting those those you know
dysfunctional belief systems
you know gangs you know I wanted I
wanted to be part of the gang I'm going
to be I want the city you know
understand I wanted to be down and I did
it I was brave enough to do that you not
start stealing cars I'll start smoking
weed I start selling dope I start taking
up guns I start doing all those things
juvenile delinquent kids did and I'll
start influencing other kids I really
did I start influencing other kids they
looked up to me they looked up to me and
my twin brother you know what I'm saying
we my mom kept us with money my dad even
when he came by he kept us with money
you know and and it's not to take away
from you know any other did the other
kids that was negative influences and
you know we you know I had some friends
out that I looked up to you know
understand but I had some people who
really looked up to me and they were
willing and they really followed me they
really you know was allowing me to to
being a negative influence on them and
and I regret it no I'm saying I lost my
life at 15 years old I got life and I
didn't even understand how serious it
was at that time you're not saying
because I was a hurt kid you know no one
never really understood that you know
understand I was I had all these kids I
had all these tennis but I was a hurt
kid you found out saying I I love my mom
you know I said I wanted a dad you know
I say my me and my twin you know we had
a we loved each other but our
relationship was dysfunctional they
understand but we love each other we
used to fight about everything everybody
know that so it ain't no secret but you
know I'm saying you just I wanted to fit
in I wanted to be I want to fit in and I
didn't a lot of people didn't even
understand that I was the one I was
really seeking the approval I'm not I'm
saying and that led those belief systems
that hot doctor you know what I'm saying
led me to get life in prison at 15 years
old that wasn't normal
you didn't hear in 1996 a kid getting
life in prison that wasn't normal and
that's because the gang epidemic has a
grew so much to where we was destroying
our communities a lot of people was
dying so there was changing laws and it
was coming down hard
members in Los Angeles Pete Wilson and
all these lawmakers in you know these
are the things that I found out a lot of
years you know when I was studying the
prison and learning about myself but you
know I got life at 15 in it if I didn't
even understand the seriousness of it
I was so childish I was so immature
I was so naive as in kid because I was a
child it was it was it happened so fast
to me you know I had my mom who was hurt
that I was even in that situation she
couldn't understand it either you know
and you know they they gave me life and
I remembered the day I got a life I
walked into Turin squirt Municipal Court
adult court holding tank I drag and
found guilty guess it is to life I told
myself I would never get out of jail
again
I was fifteen years old telling myself
that because I already now I made me
understand my situation in stone and Sam
and I wanted to CDC I went into prison
the Department of Corrections already
knowing and believing as a child that I
was never getting out of jail so I lost
hope right then and there you know
saying and I watched my mom deteriorate
and but I still didn't see I didn't see
the pain I caused my mother you know not
just to myself my mother you know but
most of all I didn't even understand
what I did to my victim the pain I
caused him because of the life I chose
you know what I'm saying if I would
never be in a game and probably never
did I went never did life in prison and
that's what that ultimately comes down
to for me as a man growing up as a man
and understanding my responsibility in
my world and the choices I made
and while I'm at right now is because I
chose games we using help you make that
position with other kids neighborhood
friend it was it was audio but it was
not having my dad around I grew up in a
single-parent home where my mom was
birthed all the time she never was at
home she couldn't she couldn't control
this I had so much free time as a child
who were soon as I stayed outside there
we go
and my mom you know she spoiled us so
she gave us a lot of freedom and we took
advantage of straight up bottom line I
took advantage of the freedom that my
mom gave me as a good mother and I
brought pain to her life about paying to
my life and ultimately
I brought pain to my babies and I regret
every bit of it and I had to do 22 years
in prison I had to suffer I had to I had
to learn how to become a man in prison
and I suffered god and and humanity put
me through it it was part of it was part
of my growth it was part of me being
held accountable for the choices that I
did you know I got hurt I hurt people
I've been I've been held accountable I
mean in trouble after I got it got life
in prison that's why I did 22 years the
first time I was eligible for parole was
2003 I could have got out but I was so
caught up into gangs I was so caught up
into that lifestyle two hours I didn't
have no hope I didn't want to come home
because I was content with spending the
rest of my life in jail but when I lost
my mother when I lost my mother on her
deathbed she asked me to change my life
but it wasn't that she asked my big
brother to get me out of jail and my big
brother try now let me say this my big
brother
my big brother tried his best to get me
out of prison
but he couldn't I was guilty for what I
did I had to get myself out of prison I
had to do too
I had to do the big major work I had to
change my life I had to walk away for
the gangs
that's what my whole life was about I
had to walk away from it in order for me
to regain my life sentence to get an
opportunity to live back out in the free
world I had to walk away from gangs I
had to choose gangs or my freedom
I did that already I gave my life to it
already I Oh God
my victim my family my community and
myself I deserved
I deserved another chance I had to do it
I had to give myself another chance and
I walked away from him and it took me
years to get out of prison because I had
to change my belief system gangs is a
lifestyle that's what a lot of people
don't understand it's a lifestyle as a
way of thinking you understand what I'm
saying
and I had no choice but to go through
the process of changing my belief system
adopted new beliefs is when I start
believing in God God start teaching me
how to love when I started loving myself
that's when I start loving others and
that's when I learned how to take
responsibility for my behavior that's
when I learned with empathy and remorse
and with compassion is I start putting
myself and my victim shoes who had to
who has to live every day of his life
for what I did he has to live with that
and I'm and I'm sorry and I apologize
and so I made a promise that I'm gonna
change my life even if I make mistakes
but I made a promise that I would never
again participate in violence again in
my life I'm gonna get out and I'm gonna
live my life productive and I'm gonna
learn how to love I'm gonna learn how to
be car and I'm learn how to be
respectful you know but it was my
mother's death that changed my life
and she died she died in prison and it
was hard for me I never I never but I
was back at square one again
I lost my mother and I've got life in
prison
what the hell am i living for
what the what the hell am i living for
and and I'm telling you a lot of people
know me so you really putting this story
on do to people is gonna tell you he's
telling the truth
cuz everyone knows my mother and
everyone knows me and everyone knows my
truth and I'll tell you this right now
it was my mother's death that ultimately
changed my life I old her I owed her so
much and the biggest apology I could
ever give my mother was getting out of
prison and I'm telling you it was a
journey and it was a process and I made
mistakes as a man I made mistakes on my
journeys getting out who doesn't it was
a journey it was a mission and I
accomplished it I went in front of the
board of prison terms on my seven-ton my
sub six and convinced him that I'm no
longer a threat to society because I got
my GED because I got my education
because I took responsibility for the
choices and the things I did in my life
and I showed remorse in empathy
to my victim his family of my community
the people who I hurt and destroy and I
did that my change in my life I did that
by loving people in prison I did that by
helping people in prison I did that by
educating myself and others in prison I
did the footwork and I got out of prison
that's prison I did that nun I'm in a
free world look
I'm the most happiest frustrated man in
the world
you're installing us and because I'm
happy that I'm out I haven't been out in
a free world since I was 15 years old
the first thing kind of my mind is I I
never gave myself a chance to live
here's the opportunity Gary go what can
I do but then on the other hand is it's
hard to live out here
now reality is just sucking in from me
I'm back at square one again but the but
the beautiful thing is is that I'm free
but the frustrating thing is then now I
have to learn how to be a productive
successful stable man in a free world
because if you don't have money you
cannot survive in a free world and me I
come from an era where we don't have
money we resort back to crime I can't do
that I'm not gonna do that it's not an
option it's not a choice for you so I
have to be broke I have to starve I have
to sleep on the ground I have to sleep
in a tent I have to check into into a
homeless shelters but my situation is
not because I don't have no no nowhere
to go is that since I've been in jail
all my resources are gone I've been
going all my life my resources are
limited you understand what I'm saying
and I'm not out here begging did I have
a job absolutely I had a job but I was
working for a company that was hiring
and firing I'm only working 30 hours a
week I need an apartment I need to make
I need a car you know even if I need to
over I need to over I need the bus it
costs money to survive out here in a
free world and it's frustrating and I'm
not out here robbing nobody I'm not on
her son or daughter
I'm not doing none of that I'm just out
here trying to survive and learn how to
live in his heart and it's frustrating
but I'm doing it and and and you know I
tell you know when I got out of prison I
thought it was gonna be cold for me I
really did and I'm not I'm not trying to
cry again of that because I'm not doing
that but it's the truth
I miss my mother but at the same time
I'm like that's the biggest apology I
gave him he was getting out of prison
because I put myself in prison and I got
myself out and since I've been out it's
been a trying era and I'm out a year
later yeah you know I'm living I'm
struggling it but I'm healthy and I know
where I'm at in my life I know where I'm
going and I know where I need to be and
that's the most important thing and I'm
still focused I understand consequences
I understand that what I do not only
just affect me but everyone around me so
long as I continue to think like that
I'm gonna stay mindful if not behavior
I'm gonna stay focused because I'm a
good man and that's my intention and
that's my desire and that's my only goal
is to just survive out here and make an
honest living and if I can get become
successful Hey that's God's plan
but that's all I just want to live my
life
making sure your story